[музыка]
первый день это адаптация наша цель
первого дня затормозить все процессы в
голове потому что вроде в экспедиции а
голова еще в городе
мы будем продолжать думает от тех
работах о тех проблемах не так далее
причем скорость мышления будет еще
осталась той же наша задача остановить
эту скорость замедлить до этого все
нужно не спеша и основать
[музыка]
магия
да у него не полосы 2 баги два пассажира
даже физически начинайте затормаживать
физически то есть потому что мы много из
города когда приходит продолжает еще
смутить или просто начните все люди как
эстонские
не спеша спокойно потому что в степи по
уму ли ритм жизни совсем другой
биологические часы другие наша задача
перестроить мелодических чист и
ментальные часы
привет давай
[музыка]
detox начался сейчас очень важный момент
1 рождения человека а.н. avatar 1
аватар мирбек его мне вам милан форм
город мина билан все
мерного
гербе касался городе
милан прошу любить и жаловать ландыш кто
и
от тебя ты меня фаншо приехал оскар от
имени алтая сами едет осаду от имени
моди в нашу экспедицию едет майк от
имени таланта в нашу экспозицию едет
олень и меня рената яде с нами а реки от
имени марк мир все
ними мы закончили связь мы проверили
воду взяли инструктаж провели
теперь по машинам и начинаем ехать
[музыка]
но
друзья добро пожаловать называется
каньон сайт те кто был в америке у нас
есть и те кто был в америке на ли
посещали такой каньон как золото
антилопа пала это вот наш ответ
популярное название называется ажурный
каньон здесь принципе сейчас можете
замерить в ощущении по температуре и
какая температура будет поговорим
овны рисовать
[музыка]
внезапно я опять произошло дороге всегда
один не продуманный поступок может сразу
перечеркнуть все движение у нас машина
застряла теперь роста иного
[музыка]
палатку вещи положили от рехнулись это
всегда закрывайте что-то ничего не
залетело не заползла на ночь глядя
мы закроем окошке чтобы не задохнулись
не было бы у них не так холодно здесь
ведь и вы играете люблю вот вторая
солдат на 9 компаньона партнеров
палатки у каждого будет вы сводите сих
пор не подойду запишу вовсе шлема чтобы
это именно ваш личный шикарное ребята
вернулись
отличная новость покатались устали
сейчас поужинают сейчас просто приведем
один удар стали камешки 12 часов за
рулем настолько проедем
представься окорока
[музыка]
вот целый день из валялись пыли грязи
потом приехали искупались kospi вот
теперь с казахским чай
провожая солнце закат что еще нужно
для простого казарского счастья
[музыка]
второй день это вспоминая детство это не
случайная поставил я по себе знаю что
почему то после того как я отхожу от
города у меня очень часто я вспоминаю
детство
вспоминайте только лучшие моменты
детства и молодости
дальше смакуйте каждый момент заново
посмейтесь над курьезными случайно
которые были в детстве я очень часто
бывает так что недоверчиво с помощью
смеюсь это уже давно нет но я сам самый
раз я смеюсь
поэтому вспоминаете веселые случае
курьезные случаи тот поминаете лучший
момент идет
весна
ребенку кто не проходил жеребец
4 баги без переводится на штабе до
[музыка]
сейчас уколу ник колонна cola alto
жарко ведь хочется еще захочется тушка
прохладен году во всем .
да пусть как мечтать не большая
маленькая осуществить эту
это просто нереально прямо родниковая
холодная вода сегодня мы ехали 47
градусов 40 бы все плотные пыльные и
грязные единственное о чем все мечтали
меня спрашивали а можно под когда где-то
искупнуться
и у нас по плану не было но из-за того
что наш бусик перегрелся они от нас
отстали мы вынуждены стали на остановку
самого подогнал такой родник с такой
водой просто какая-то старца
пятачок мечтал ехал
[музыка]
ты 5
на
[музыка]
надо
а
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
третий день размышление о смысле жизни
здесь нужно вспоминать только а всем
хорошим что у вас уже есть поминайте что
у вас есть семья есть 9 есть визит все
хорошие вспоминаете только все хорошее
что у вас есть эта первых дальше думать
только своих близких и любимых людях и
друзьям дальше думать о том как сделать
так чтобы ваша жизнь наполнилась
еще большим хороший то есть когда вы так
про бывает и вы начинаете понимать и
ценить то что у вас есть хорошие и уже у
вас есть образец
какую часть вашей жизни надо увеличены
какую хорошую часть надо увеличить
баталии
[музыка]
мы находимся в пещере было юг который
находится в 50 двух километрах от
заповедника horn жарык на юго-востоке
сама пещера представляет все просто
огромную диаметры на это метров 30 на 40
пещеры глубиной более 100 метров для
того чтобы вам представить это около 35
этажный обязательно спускаться с
фонариком с веревками
женщинам и детям не рекомендуется сюда
спускаться потому что спуске очень
сложной и каменистые на дне пещеры
находятся вот такое озеро и вообще
складывается впечатление что
происхождение этой пещеры
оно такое геологическое этот не обвал
даже был скорее всего это был огромный
подземный водный резервуар и вода
бурлила она подтачивал а прям видно как
своды пещеры преамп оттачивались по
качестве подтачивали как будто свернем
его на пробивалась наверх и видать за
миллионы лет вода пробилась наверх а
потом уровень либо kospel полны по
подземных вод и водовод ушла вниз а
пещера
так и осталась
[музыка]
как вы
насколько он пролетел щас мне не то там
чуть меня прошивками на меня пошел
20 методом пока игра на пк asus в каске
вырубил бы конечно
поролон коллеги видели как что было как
осадным свалился да да да слышались я
честно говоря переживал думаю поцарапает
стекло каскелене
[музыка]
воды и ни туды и ни сюды
егор
на
[музыка]
четвертый день на размышление о
проблемах во-первых отстраненный взгляд
на проблему второе думать
проблема какая проблема в другого
человека который остался в город дальше
позвольте проблеме случится подумайте о
самом худшем что может случиться
прочувствуйте настолько ли она важна
[музыка]
процесс подготовки входит очень много
мероприятий эта подготовка лагерного
снаряжения и транспортное обеспечение
этой логистика это и смысловой контент
теле фото-видео съемки это безопасно с
отдельным блоком идет очень много
компонентов
как правило в подготовку экспедиции а
стоит ли менее 10 а то и 15 человек по
разных ключевая цель этой экспедиции
чтобы люди которые привыкли комфорту
жить в городе
находиться в зоне комфорта чтобы они
переоценили те ценности которые у них
уже есть и переосмыслили свою будущую
жизнь для чего ниже
[музыка]
размещаем часть костей которые до верха
и дойдут но уже сделала для рекорд с
нами
участника экспедиции с ником госпожа
ее сейчас размещаем в тень
[музыка]
поломка ремонт у меня вот эти спицы за
техника я отвечаю здесь даже не думали
чтобы такая жара
как спасаешься джерри вот на девайс
руководили
вот у нас есть
два называть на голову одеваешь
вот так отдел
кепочка
и все нормально
вот видишь как она измеряется просто
измеряет поворот к дома реально щас как
сковородке ничего адаптивным сегодня
вроде было где-то вот в районе 48 49
а может быть и больше вот до чего
доводит высокая температура после такой
же вид нужно обязательно лучше и
отдохнуть немножко и готовы на дорогу
привыкли спать и 47 50 градусов
но решили поменять сейчас будет поезд на
пике тату и оттуда на обзоре есть
вращаться здесь больше каждая
и сегодня мы решили заночевать здесь
потому что прошла ночь нам всем здесь
понравилось
[музыка]
муза ложкам бетона
пятый день день мечтаний или думая о
будущем
значит что вы в этот день делай мечтаем
просто свободный полет дальше
представляем свою идеальную жизнь
проживаем в этой идеальной жизни
мысленно представляем себе идеальный
день и проживаем это идеальный жизнь как
бы я сидел на какой машине ездил бы там
шёл бы себе купил лось отлично ваши
набор
блин такой природе
как можно не выспится хорошего строение
[музыка]
хороший сон свежий воздух хорошая еда
хороший леди
[музыка]
пушков
.
[музыка]
после вчерашних zara
утром отключился утром проснуться
успокоитель оступись и не упускаю момент
из дачных
потолка
нужно
ничего
я что и
мальчики
рычит
а на дорогу туда видео сейчас я выскочу
пробили колесо да пробили колесо товарищ
счете совсем скажи по рации ему сейчас
наберу
скажи макса то чтобы он позвонил туда и
пусть они уже кушать готовят на гостей
всех и размещает хорошо давайте от каких
только побыстрее
[музыка]
поехали очень большому маршрут были
короткие остановки
у нас побольше бы две остановки это
более 300 он прав скорее всего проехали
по ландшафтам я вижу пегас нахожусь
прикольно вся будем спать не не в
палатке
а viewty национальном духе после после
этой поездки в степи юрта для нас как
рицко аулы
для нас как дубая короче новые
впечатление новое понимание пришло
столько инсайты получившийся с
потихоньку перевариваю почему я раньше
этого не знал такие действия игил сейчас
меня уже переосмысление правда идет во
всем рекомендуем если будет возможность
и по времени на следующем туре попасть
не пропускай сегодняшний день было
реально интересна сама удивительно эту
сумму еще от этой поездки каждый не
узнаешь от
своих товарищей по экспедиции все каждое
новое это интересно когда меня не станет
я буду пей голосами
моих детей и голосами из детей
с просто меняют местами гол закон сам
оскар и
круговорот людей сейчас нужен женский
голос
[музыка]
когда меня не станет я буду весь
голосами и детей
галсами давай топи в сторону трассы и не
в сторону маната
[музыка]
говард youth
мои
вам
[музыка]
я буду петь голосами
шестой день планы и реализации начинаем
думать о приоритизации меч у вас уже
появилось несколько личных продумаем
этапы и шаги достижениями уже начинает
думать об этапах шага оцениваем свои
возможности и ресурсы и сколько нам
осталось и что надо делать для того
чтобы добить этим
тартар падем 8 уже ага реке
козерог нормалью пойдем на 50 минут
позже потому что вчера приехали уставшие
больше трехсот километров серафин
диагностики 0
[музыка]
а
сказать
[музыка]
финальный день придерживал sunlit что
хотят быть что нужно выезжать завтра не
хотят уезжать не хотят уезжать все нужно
по классике делать катарсис должен
завтра заступить когда мы все разъедемся
bagel су-34 и смотрите 3 до 1 маги
первый водитель стой как раз хотел по
заказу
сделали
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
раз произошло небольшое т.п. вначале
когда уж
услышал я испугался о
оскар на полном ходу корпуса 2 раза
через голову на баги слава аллаху все
живы здоровы
небольшие ушиба ноги-руки самое главное
это то что все живы здоровы но все-таки
он хорошо сделан вот это-то мощная рама
+ 4 точечный ремень прямых удержала на
местные их не выкинуло из баки вот это
очень классно мне павлин что это
все-таки
плане безопасности хорошо отработаны ну
а сейчас мы решаем партнеров я маршрут
прорисовываем потому что нам придет
сейчас разделиться на два и одна команда
пойдет буксировать баги автора команда
по id на по
звучит длинный а для бисера
arma зависть
работать на счет сегодня авары была
хороша типа катались ребята
вот теперь на вкусили тащи
blogger
взял аптечки
[музыка]
ну словами не описать как бы по сути эта
поездка была для меня практически
применением power management
очень крутая команда
общее
все-таки молодцы я видел как они в
команде работают это вот мне понравилось
что мы сплотились как команда не знаю
как так получилось в каждом из вас мы
начинаем узнавать себя в первую очередь
те к айфону муками
от нашего общества да то есть все
разносторонние люди такие
наверное не то что места а вот именно
ощущения свободы когда едешь ветер в
лицо и не хочется кричать
а вам вам минтранском автономов сервер
им даже энергия стал сатурн
4 минус бизнес мира роста новости мерьем
light up the door начале я конечно
сомневалась стоит ли мне ехать но когда
увидела программу мне безумно захотелось
мангуста у меня всегда была мечта
проехаться просто для себя посмотреть
природу в такое чувство как будто мы на
другой планете абсолютно до такой pitch
тени к будет это не казахстан или дней
планеты земля
а куда-то на марс попали я здесь просто
наслаждалась природой общением с
ребятами и
и по большей части я молчала и смеялась
что такие
веро ощущение спокойствия у меня
появились другие взгляды на нашу родину
во первых такую природу я не ожидал авто
именно на западном казахстане я столько
красивых мест этот наверное думает и вся
счастья это мелочах вот это мы реально
почувствовали и продаваться с каждым
моментом здесь все те места красивые
сиськи и жажды все эти за которых
достопримечательности так вот класса
чередуются и скажут пятьдесят сто
километров там все резко все меняется ее
своей просто то самое удивительное
прошлому еще от этой поездки каждый день
узнаю shot своих товарищей по экспедиции
все каждое новое
как отец рекомендуем если будет
возможность
и по времени на следующем туре попасть
не пропускайте
просит и живешь и тем меньше ты
начинаешь себя
вставить рамки темы жизненно становится
очень прекрасно чувствует ощущение
счастья надо было очень интересно за
разговором вечерами нас отпускала карбон
ну мне больше наверно в этот раз
запомнилось .
люди всех разные истории
интересно у всех людей такое ощущение
что люди все приходят
разными тропами и когда все они всходят
в одной точке вот это вот интересное
впечатление создается
[музыка]